panthers gm scott fitter spoke to the
media on on friday and i almost said
saturday because it's the first day of
the weekend but that was for me not for
you uh it was day two for you but anyway
here's fitter talking about the
quarterback they've recently acquired
via trade from the jets
and whether or not they're gonna pick up
his fifth year option there's a report
that they are
let's listen to fitter on whether or not
that's actually the case
will your decision on sam's fifth year
option be impacted at all by what you do
in the draft
no we have a plan in place and that's
something we'll address
after the draft and that's what we're
focused on right now but we have a plan
in place
is that the expectation to
again we'll talk about it after the
draft but yes we do have a strong plan
in place
you know what when i saw the words i
thought one thing when i saw that i
think something else i think they are
picking up the option on sam darnold
yeah i think it would take something
extremely unforeseen for them to not do
it but but
if a quarterback falls to them if one of
the top guys falls to them it has to be
a guy that the owner david tepper really
wants
do you pick up the fifth year option on
sam darnold do you try to flip him to
someone else and get back some of the
draft picks you gave up i mean it
occurred to me on saturday there's a
chance if they get the guy that they
otherwise would have traded up for
if he falls to them and they didn't have
to trade up for him right they probably
gave up less to get darnold than they
would have given up to move up to get
the guy that falls to them at eight so
you know it could be genius here this
could be next level stuff david tepper
is doing where you buy insurance
and then you'll wait and see how the
board plays out and if it plays out to
your favor and you get a quarterback
then you just unload the guy that you
gave up three draft picks to get well i
mean i i'd be shocked i'd be shocked if
that that did happen i'd be shocked that
like if they didn't pick up the fifth
year option for for sam darnold you know
they made they traded pretty significant
value to get a guy like that i would
just be surprised now you know i mean
from all appearances it seems like the
guy they wanted was mac jones i mean i
don't think it's a coincidence the 49ers
trade up to number three and then like
three days later the panthers are
trading for sam darnold i mean i think
that says something let alone they
coached mac jones in the senior bowl the
panthers coaching staff so there's just
too many things that make me think
that's what they wanted but i think
they've made their bed now i mean i
would be shocked no matter who it was or
whoever they fancied i would think
they're going with sam darnold he fits
the way they want to play donald has
talent you know i would think they did
this because they like donald 2 and what
he brings to the table here so
i mean listen it's an interesting theory
i don't know but i would just be shocked
they've done so many smart things with
their roster to me
even if the quarterback they wanted fell
to them at number eight right now
i just think it brings more headaches
than it does positive things than just
to make a pick that for another need on
their football team
so why wouldn't they just go ahead and
pick up the option are they trying to
make others think that they're waiting
for a quarterback maybe to me maybe get
the broncos to jump them right the
quarterback pushes down the guy they
want i think so mike that's at least
what it seems like to me right i mean
they're just they're they're kind of
just like they don't want to say it
they're going to play like the koi like
to what you said oh maybe the panthers
still have a quarterback they have on
their either eye on everything like that
i think they're playing that game i
really would be surprised if they they
ended up taking a quarterback at number
eight and open up the can of worms there
you know who's to say where's sam
darnold gonna go what are you gonna do
with them right now i mean that to me
then i'd be going well that was a dumb
trade i don't know what to say you got a
what a a backup quarterback or a guy you
got a year for a year before you start
some other rookie quarterback you take
it eight and you traded all those assets
so i just would be shocked if that was
the move they made
but that's when you put david tebber out
there to say look it was too expensive
to trade up after the 49ers blew the
curve by giving up two first round picks
and a three to go from 12 to three there
was no way we were going to give up what
we had to give up to move up so we just
thought we'd we'd give up far less
see if it worked out and now we decided
you know hey the guy that we never
thought would be there was there and
we're going to move forward and chris
look to get back to where we started
if the 49ers do take trey lance
yeah are the falcons taking mack jones
are the bengals taking mack jones are
the dolphins taking mack jones are the
lions taking mack jones unless somebody
trades up
mack jones could fall to the panthers at
eight oh i think he would and i think
that's when we hear the phone call and
it said um um hi this is bill
belichick's dog
i'm looking to trade for a quarterback
for bill i'm the dog you saw on tv last
year i mean that's when i started i
think you start to hear those kind of
calls
teams like like a patriots who's been
rumored to like mac jones and everything
like that maybe they start to get
involved and make a move so i don't know
it'd be interesting this whole
quarterback thing is interesting you
could lay out you know a few different
scenarios where really mac jones trey
lance justin fields they all could fall
in some way um but as i said here right
now i think the one that i look at that
i think is going to fall a little bit is
justin fields just for the things we've
talked about today uh we'll see but it's
interesting between the 49ers the
panthers you know and who's gonna be the
odd guy out of these five quarterbacks
gonna be fun to watch
you know i'm trying to remember last
year when we saw the picture of bill
belichick's dog i just don't think
that chris sims imitating phil sims
trying to talk like a dog is the voice
that would come probably not of bill
belichick's dog i think it's a little
higher pitch it's a little higher
a little higher range not not squeaky
it's it's not one of those little one of
those little dogs that you can fit in
your purse
it's mid-range i thought my might talk
more like a dog like i talk more like
bill and just be like
just more like that
uh i i think that belichick wouldn't
want a dog like that around him because
then that dog would never want that dog
would not be in the same room as bill
you need to have the the differences in
personality doesn't work two curmudgeons
doesn't work together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports